over here in chin wearing now let's just
get into it man yeah Brian's late eft-1
sends me it takes it goes bro lost track
of time be there soon
who loses track of time I don't even
know what that is by the way I don't
even know what losing track of time is
but here's the problem we've been doing
the show for six years
yeah it's the same time every Wednesday
yeah if it but it's so you know it's not
like oh it's a crazy Thursday yeah
except I suppose whatever I guess it was
just me I'm used to it
yeah I do too I still have inner demons
mm thing about killing Brian would he'd
be late to me I probably quit the show
four to five times because he's late all
the time yeah and they stop being late
he hasn't been late in a while yeah it
used to be a real problem
yeah I'm just like a chalk it up it's
Brian yeah but you can kind of see that
with Brian's progression in life he lost
track it's always been losing track of
yeah and now it's really hitting them
and now it's like hey i'ma do a special
it's like I think he lost track of time
yeah that should have been done 15 years
ago but yeah hey good job will promote
person used to look who's late
look who's lost track of time yeah
you're 50 though yeah how's that happen
I am okay I know I can trust you guys
not to make fun man you're ready for the
worst lie you've heard what I've been
doing for quite some time I could
understand get ready spread around can I
say this to you guys without you guys
making fire me 100%
it's not my son start zero like they're
so bad at the same they're so bad it
makes my day huh Bay yeah yeah yeah I
had to walk my dog I had to make
breakfast that's not an excuse yeah I
understand yeah I'll take a shot that's
not ice cream you don't have a donut
your partner this is a vulnerable for me
I have a case of the squirts
there you go all right yeah you're so
much more creative yeah I am
but it's so much more creative yeah at
least come up with something yeah and my
husband oh just bad
that's a lie you know excuse me well
you're a liar this this strain just
keeps on going done it yeah it's the
fighter in the coin now what role you're
out this thing no no ha ha you remember
that that whole thing where you lose
track of time
yeah this is what happens during that
time listen you lose track of time yeah
that little that area that you miss yeah
it gets build in people forget about
people forget check now it's a comment
now it's Brendan Connor those two
comments 7,000 negative ones negative
now it's Brendan chicoy yeah oh boy it's
your coy boys in the house everyone
chicoy I'll do you would laugh at this I
really don't like you I don't even know
why do I don't even know why come on
dude I don't have the anger anymore but
when Brian used to be late if he's
younger I swear to God my just saying
this I would I'd want to fight you oh
you would
yeah yeah not anymore though I'm good
not older rich whatever used to does it
matter used to want to fight does it
matter anyway that'd be I'd be like that
twenty five minutes then I was will
sasso late yeah I used to be real
satellite in this room this was all I
had at the time yeah like I'm gonna I'm
gonna fisticuff yeah oh I want to hurt
him but you're too old yeah it would
ruin my reputation yeah but if I were
younger if you were you might have given
me a shot of what you are you were to
give me a shove about no wait a minute
love hold on yeah if he was 30 Hey 31 is
Shawn
jardim audience your course seriously
you know I joke oi well no you know I
don't have time to call your whole name
to you I say if he has the hottest
special on Netflix and you met you can't
you show up late dude your special looks
very fun oh why cuz Hollywood be lower
to ranked him top-five comics in the
you're doing well
in the world do you know why because I
didn't sell out Brea and then somebody
goes dude my agent goes jo koy saw that
like 70 times went and that doesn't help
her jaws hurt I'm not him yeah her jaw
hurts your feelings no it doesn't hurt
my feelings
he's the best yeah like this doctor
lighter in the koi not in the koi no I
don't know what color paint we're gonna
use for my face on that wall but no come
on look what we're actually moving
Studios MO today dude what do you were
aa young close he looks awesome I think
right I know how to put it together
we're not young I'm not I'm not doing
the whole laundry day look that you like
to do this is that cash like hey I got
to do my laundry tonight there's a wall
casters what I had I got it Vince
that's not tonight's game here yes see
that's not can't feel it
what is cashmere what is it you want to
know yeah what is it it's a sheep it's a
type of sheep that comes from the
Kashmir Valley oh yeah
depends where Kashmir what's mellow what
happened bro what happened that's not
what it is right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]